the Biden Administration has once again
extended a pause on paying back student
loans until at least sometime next year
it comes as Republican challenges
continue challenges to the president's
plan to cancel student debt for millions
of Americans and we're gonna go to Zhang
now who's traveling with the president
in Nantucket for the Thanksgiving
holiday weisha good morning Happy
Thanksgiving
Happy Thanksgiving to all of you and
everyone at home this is the eighth time
that payment pause has been put into
place since it first started back in
March 2020 as a result of the pandemic
now borrowers were set to resume those
payments on January 1st but you're right
now they are on hold until 60 days after
a lawsuit is resolved or 60 days after
June 30th whichever comes first the
Biden Administration asked the Supreme
Court to review a lower Court ruling
that blocks the debt forgiveness plan
President Biden tweeted a video saying
he is completely confident his plan is
legal and that the White House will not
back down the Department of Education
says of the 26 million applicants 16
million applications have already been
approved but legal challenges have left
them in limbo the plaintiffs in the
lawsuit Six republican-backed States say
President Biden's executive action
exceeds his authority and it no longer
addresses the economic effects of the
pandemic now the supreme court ordered
those states to respond to the
administration's request for a review by
noontime today than after that the
Supreme Court will decide whether to
take the case Nate
Ouija thank you